a barrage of missile strikes across
Ukraine hitting critical infrastructure
the second day the country's power grid
has come under attack
like at this plant in denipro
and this one
Ukrainian officials expect more attacks
in the days ahead
the terrorist States Russia is making
every effort to destroy the Ukrainian
Energy System the main target is not
only the peaceful Ukrainian civilians
but also critical infrastructure
in kiev's destinyansky District power
facilities were hit by three missiles
leaving many areas in the dark
for residents of this apartment complex
concerns are growing
they have done the same again last
Monday and today they attacked us again
and it wasn't just the electricity they
worried about
water wasn't flowing either
63 year old Valentina has lived in this
neighborhood for 30 years and she's
upset
this time they hit the factory as a
conclusion we have no electricity and no
hot water and children cannot study at
home or at school
this is very painful very painful for
our children and grandchildren
for now the residents wait hoping
utilities will come back online soon
Ukrainian officials say 30 percent of
the country's power plants have been
damaged by Russian shelling since
October 10th and add that more blackouts
are possible they're urging citizens to
limit their consumption of electricity a
critical warning as winter approaches
and temperatures continue to drop